so I watched this movie officially
records yeah what movie did you watch
last night I'm
recording Society of the
snow oh yeah Spanish film yes um
absolutely loved it like about tell
let's let's pretend some of us on the
cool have never heard of this film
before and might want like a little just
for the sake of the
listener for the second list I'm gonna
turn my mic down you are really L I'm
really freaking l excessively loud um
it's based on the uh it's a Uruguayan
flight that crashes over the Andes like
the mountain range that happened in
1970s um it's a real thing that happened
and it was mostly a Uruguayan rugby team
um and I think they survived for
something like 60 days even though at
nighttime it was minus
32 um just like
All Odds Against them every odd in the
world against them and it's funny
watching the movie which again I think
is really fantastic not only is it
really well shot they also do some
really interesting perspective things to
make sure that the people who died are
very well advocated for
um and and most of the people who
perspective things what do you I don't
want to spoil it uh because there there
is a choice that they make that is a
perspective thing um and most of the
people who who lived are like make
cameos in the movie as well so they're
they're all because especially after May
December came out and I think the person
who was uh May December is a movie about
grooming and I think the person who was
the victim in real life of the May
December scenario was like yeah
Hollywood really this up uh it
was nice to see so many people regarding
Society of the snow be like this gave me
closure and I really appreciate that it
it came together and it's also just it's
so harrowing um and awful to watch that
it makes the movie feel long but it's
like this is such a weird comparison but
I struggle to think of many things other
than like The Last of Us Part Two that
did this where it makes you feel like
it's lasting a long time at the same
rate that it would for them like you
also feel the burden rather than it
being like the movie poorly paced in
anyway it's not um and it's
also the story famously in order to
survive for that long they had to become
cannibals so it's technically not
considered cannibalism if it's for
survival purposes apparently it has a
different word um but it's obviously a
very big
theme where and also very famously they
basically ended up promising their
bodies to each other so that everyone
consented they were like if I die you're
allowed to eat me I want to make sure
that my death is not in vain and that
you all go on to live like feel free to
do that um and at
first I think I felt pretty disgusted
and then by the end at the rate that
they become very desensitized to it you
also become very desensitized to it it
just does a really good job of uh again
the last was part two like the the
another thing that I feel like did this
expertly well of making you feel the
same way that the people felt without it
being minus 32 degrees Fahrenheit
Celsius um it's not
the the same story that the film alive
is yes but I've never seen a lot about
but it is the same it's a it's a new
take on that story right not just a
similar one but it's it's literally the
exact story and it's um a take on the
book Society of the snow which was
written by one of the survivors uh
whereas alive I think is based on like a
bunch of interviews or something um
right yeah but it it is exactly the same
thing um yeah and yeah it's it's a yeah
it's a pretty famous story pretty
wellknown um supposedly like
exceptionally famous in in Uruguay for
obvious reasons and it's like the stuff
these guys did man
like you think about so there's a point
where like somebody has to hike for like
30 miles
um 10 days of hiking and I'm like I
couldn't do that and then you think
about these people doing that while
starving to death and in freezing
conditions think they were rugby players
well I honestly think the the fact that
they were rugby players because there's
no I just mean athletes like for sure
seemingly a better shot at and they're
really they young men like they they
statistically were going to do better
than a lot of people um none of the
women survived
uh but I think the fact that they were a
rugby team helped them very
significantly and that like at least
none of the material that I found
touches on any kind of Lord of the Flies
conflict like they had a leader right uh
they had each other's backs uh there
wasn't a villain among the group um
which definitely a Hollywood adaptation
I feel like would have done but I don't
know if alive actually did that or not
um but they're all already understand
like it's it's like there's no egos in
play where there might be if you had a
plane of a bunch of people didn't know
each other so because they're already
operating as a team when any of them
comes up with and they come up with some
really smart stuff that it's like nuts
like they realize that they could get
snow blindness uh which is basically
blindness caused by the white of the
snow um so they fashion glasses using
the visor that was in the cockpit and
straps from bras and some wire and they
just share these three pairs of glasses
somebody makes uh uh solar like water
system so that they have water um it's
all like just seems so smart and I feel
like that also probably comes from not
being worried about your survival where
so many of these stories you hear about
people killing each other or you know
like like I said a hierarchy but because
they already figure out they already
know their hierarchy they know who the
captain is he's already being the
captain um it just seems like their odds
of surviving were better even though
it's still they called off the search
because they were so sure that there was
no way that these guys lived so they
called it off after eight days um it's
yeah it's just like technically those
are spoilers but it's a real thing that
happened in the 70s uh and it I just
felt like the movie did such a good job
of taking me along the journey with
these people and I was constantly
shocked and and like Disturbed and it's
so well shot um but yeah it just kept me
like toe and toe I think is it also uh I
feel like it's also a firsttime director
um oh I don't know J bua is his name and
I know they actually shot significant
parts of it actually in the mountains
where it
happened um and they shot it over a long
period of time and shot sequentially to
make sure that the guys were losing
weight at the correct rate like they
were actually losing the weight one of
them I was reading yesterday because I
love like watching a movie like this
stupid definitely not a first time
director I'd be very surprised because
he's so good nothing that they can't be
but um well as in terms of features
sometimes people pivot in from other
things but
I'm I'm thinking of someone else clearly
because not only has he directed
multiple films but his previous film was
the last film so like picture he's doing
all right basically yeah he made his he
made his money and oh he did a couple
episodes
apparently um yeah so he
could I'm assuming that when your movie
makes over a billion dollars you have
enough you money in the to direct
whatever the you want uh after that
you know Christ much more passion
project yeah yeah it was it was just
really good so it's on Netflix I think
out in cinemas as well um came out late
last year so I'm not actually sure but
yeah I just I just thought it was like
unbelievable and yeah just reading up
some of the facts about it one of these
guys by the time that it was all done I
think they said he was
like 55 kilos like just that they're all
just these huge rugby players end up
yeah end up being just nothing and still
surviving um it's yeah it's really
really good highly recommend did either
of you see uh Godzilla minus one not yet
not yet work my way through the old
Godzilla movies for another podcast I'm
on and that has been the journey you
doing like a Godzilla podcast I'm doing
a Godzilla podcast that's cool quite fun
it's it's it it varies massively week to
week that's something the main thing is
turns out if you watch franchise that's
exactly yeah if you're a there's
definitely weeks where you're like oh
god I've gotta watch Godzilla this week
damn what's your favorite Godzilla movie
obviously the M you know what I
surprisingly quite like Godzilla versus
King Kong the like the original one that
was surprisingly decent it's not aged
well in some of its casting choices it's
a profound amount of uh blackface in
that movie but the film itself it's that
era yeah so it's like yeah but the the
film itself is is
excellent um yeah it is really retails
King Kong while while doing Godzilla you
know I I love Shin Godzilla like I I
think that that movie has you seen that
one that's not got there yet no I'm
still in the 80s I'm I'm working my way
such an interesting movie because it's
just an anime like it's just Anime made
by the same guy who made Evan gilan oh W
and so it just comes across that way
like it's even the framing is anime um
but is it pronounced
evangelon uh Evangelion is how I've
always said it
long heard understood it to be
Evangelion but I am likely to be wrong
in this department but it sounded so my
brain went what the hell word did I just
hear Evan yeah I've always said EV
but I don't think like Shi looks at the
camera and goes it's Evan gelan time so
I don't know if that's correct I'm not
sure if they ever say the word in the
anime which is also
hell minutes said the name of the thing
uh yeah I'd definitely be interested to
see what you think of shen Godzilla
because I just show I'll get there
eventually and he did not love it um but
I yeah I think it's it's so awesome I
was by how excellent the original
Godzilla actually is original I think I
I I assumed the um I assume that like
the most recent reboot like was like oh
they've they've really taken Godzilla
and made it dark and interesting you go
back and watch the original Godzilla
it's fuing terrifying it's genuinely
excellent and then it gets goofy over
the years and then swings back but yeah
related who do you think wins in a fight
like actually even though I know
technically it's happened both ways
multiple times Godzilla or Kong who
actually wins
it's got to be Kong for the smarts
Kong's got the tool making shut the
up I I get
so like you know how how many like
stupid
nerd fight this is the only one I
actually care about in what world does
just the upscaled monkey win in a fight
against a a walking
nuke by making some kind what's do
against a nucle lizard King Kong
doesn't have ranged weapons also doesn't
throw something most version of God have
effectively like range nuke fire
breathing SL laser laser shooting you
know variants depending on which we're
talking I just don't see Kong ever ever
winning again if it's bad enough that
he's a big Angry lizard right like we
have some big lizards in Australia we
have these lizards called lace monitors
they're huge and terrifying and
they could rip apart a dog like they
could probably rip apart him monkey very
easily but then you you take that you
make it even bigger so it's got huge
Claws and huge teeth and it's reptilian
it's got like hard scaly body but then
it also is a nuke like I just feel
like I just feel like Kong gets
obliterated it the thicker it's like the
scaly exterior is seemingly a form of
armor compared to yeah like a fur coat
basically yeah way hotter to cut through
does that although I will God I will say
the uh the way that what is Godzilla
called godilla is like Frozen in iceberg
several times so
I'm
probably way well I think that uh being
a nuke means no there are animals nice
yeah what I was gonna say was I do think
that um that uh
the way that Kong kills the T-Rex in the
Peter Jackson King Kong by effectively
ripping its mouth open in a very sort of
Doom
style uh piece
of that was a believable Kong kills
Godzilla move uh if Godzilla could get
in position to pull one of those on
Godzilla then I could I could see
pulling out a ever get that
close you know the walking Godzilla has
the 70s movies you wait till Godzilla's
doing a little dance of Celebration and
then you sleep up on it yeah that's the
thing like everyone can make
an is that how godzill doesn't Godzilla
in the I I always get Gareth Evans and
Gareth Edwards confused it's Gareth
Edwards right did correct the one from
like 10 years ago the one from yeah the
newest Godzilla Breaking Bad Godzilla
yeah yeah doesn't Godzilla beat the big
bad in that by like opening the mouth
and like blasting Radioactive hisat yeah
so Godzilla even has the kind of the B K
Watch
prev could pick up a hammer if he wanted
to he just doesn't need to because he's
a walking nuke just not needed
you know what you've sold me on the
concept and especially in like the 70s
where godzill there are several moments
where he picks up a rock and throws it
at bad guy yep he thinks about it right
godilla is absolutely absolutely has the
King Kong skill set and gradi active
breath you're absolutely right I just
don't yeah I don't see it ending any
other way again there are so many of
stupid nerd conversations and I don't
care about any of them I don't care who
wins between Goku I care about this one
it just doesn't make any sense to me how
Kong could ever win and I think people
just say that because they see Humanity
in K and that's one it is it's well this
was the thing this was the thing that I
learned recently that changed my whole
the whole our monkeys in zoo sad I don't
know about you guys whenever I see like
an ape in a zoo I feel like a Pang of
like trouble going and sympathy I don't
think it stops at Apes pretty much no I
don't like Su generally but the one
thing next time someone does drag me
along to a zoo one thing that was
pointed out in this thing I was I was
listening to that had never occurred to
me is animals in zoos are on
anti-anxiety
medication they're they're not the
gorillas aren't sad they're stoned
they're allone or something also most
most zoos in like big you know at least
American cities and whatnot I would I
would think I could be wrong and I'm
sure some very like well actually
comment I'm sure that'll be in the
comments yeah my impression is that most
of these are not animals that at this
stage would even be able to survive in
the wild anyway like they they most what
if you're raced in captivity yeah like a
lot of the and many are or their rescues
from situations where they effectively
would have died um or they were they
were taken from you know like private
collector like someone was telling me
that there's like more Bengal uh there's
more Bengal tigers in America thanas
it's not even America broadly it was
like in Texas privately owned yeah how
much make a documentary about the people
doing that that would be not a bad idea
that would get us all through like the
first couple of weeks of a major
pandemic wouldn't it yeah uh I
uh yeah I never watched that one for
Tiger King uh yeah it's very we
should
time we must have talked about that at
the
time maybe I'm not sure yeah I didn't
watch it for like months uh it was part
of the whole Fire Island you know like
very or fire Festival whatever you know
like The Sensational just there was like
a animal crossing was up
there what a Time wow we are oh my God
there's going to be a Nostalgia wave for
that moment isn't there in like 20 years
there's going to be like a Nostalgia
it's already four years
ago it is surprising that it was four
years me doesn't feel like we've been
doing this podcast for four years been
doing this podcast for four years must
have's no way started before the
pandemic fulltime during Co we kind of
we kind of like documented the move into
Co via the first few episodes of this
podcast and I'm still so glad that we
were not you had a bunch of experience
or expertise there Mike because of the
games you had worked
on this yeah shitty crows of podcast
Bros who were like it's gonna blow over
man everything's gonna be fine very than
we were slightly better informed podcast
Bros as thanks to game
development yeah uh circular AV
aable yeah I I think I I um already feel
a little bit of nostalgia for for the
Animal Crossing days but like we spoke
about last episode the success of that
potentially caused people to staff up
which potentially caused tons of the
layoffs which by the way I think we've
already had a few thousand more this
year y it's not stopping that Unity just
let go of over a thousand again which
just do like as
well so Kotaku put something up that
says 10 days into 2024 and 2,300 plus
video game layoffs have been announced
which is wild I have some friends in
Australia who got laid off I don't
remember if I mentioned this last
episode or not um who got laid off
who
uh don't want to say it's not for any
fault of their own um were working for a
like blockchain Dev uh it wasn't because
they wanted to work on blockchain they
were just humans who needed jobs right
where the money was yeah um and so it
was sort of a well we'll work here uh
and work on this thing and they I think
had like a promise of getting to me make
something creative and cool once
whatever blockchain thing had had
shipped um but they all got laid off
which doesn't surprise me because that
fat clearly died and I'm surprised to
see the amount of nft conversation still
happening and there's also been um a ton
of AI art really weird AI art stuff I
don't know if you guys have seen it so
Xbox tweeted something that uh people
were pretty upset about that uh they
clearly had used AI art in the image
that they posted and Magic the Gathering
did the same thing and there's is fair
egregious um best one was the adverb for
Wacom tablets that used AI that was the
one it's like you literally sell
exclusively a product for for actually
making yeah so the the magic the
Gathering one is nuts because uh Wizards
of the Coast admits using aart after
Banning AI art so they posted something
that like in my opinion is very clearly
AI art you can see things like there's
like a dial if you zoom in on it that's
missing dial details um all the Telltale
kind
ofine yeah um like like cables that
don't go anywhere kind of stuff but then
they follow it up by
saying
[Music]
um they said we stand we understand the
confusion by fans given the style being
different than the Cod out but we stand
by our previous statement this art was
created by humans and not AI few days
later they had to say they were mistaken
um and the marketing image was made by
AI
um and it said that a human did the work
to create the overall image but AI Tools
in Photoshop crept into the mark of
creative uh the art came from rendor
it's on us to make sure that we are
living up to our promise to SM the
amazing Ingenuity that makes magic great
which I think is a really interesting
position to be in because people could
be using Ai and how would you
not like
weird yeah it's and it's and and it goes
deep on a few levels because AI is now
like integrated into a lot of workflows
whether you like it or not and it's it's
and this is by the way none of this is
like a defense or me like trying to find
a blame whatever but it's there is there
is this there are a couple of
interesting things which yes make it
basically you have to be hypervigilant
now as a as a Studio owner or someone
who's like doing marketing you have to
be thinking about this there's a couple
of reasons one is stock photography is
destroyed as a medium at this point so a
lot of the time if you're making stuff
obviously you're in a rush you'll use a
stock photography you're not going to go
out and find you know a cool looking
office which you can photograph your
magic cards in you're going to go onto a
stock Art website pay money and in
historically you pay money and then the
photographer would get a cut platform
and it was all aboveboard and very
reasonable AI stuff on stock they are
those platforms with it now some of the
some of the stock photography F sites
cuz I we I've not used it many times in
the past but it's great for placeholder
and it's and it's and we've used it a
couple of times for like very small
details and again all above board and
very legit um but we've we can't ever go
near that again because yeah there's
some of these websites have like they'll
label art as like this is AI generated
in like tiny print Under the photo which
is bad enough but then there's a lot of
people who are just uploading stuff and
nothing's getting checked so yeah if you
go into a stock photography or stock Art
website now and and I know there's going
to be a portion of the audience who go
well you should make all art from
scratch it's like that's not always an
efficient way of doing the process and
people who make stock art still get paid
and theoretically can get paid many
times over it's but yeah that's so that
side of it the other side of what seems
to have been the case here from what
they're saying is um Photoshop
generative Phil yeah which is basically
now it was it was in beta for a while
it's it's in the 2024 Photoshop I know
this because I reinstalled Photoshop the
then right there front and center as a
tool yeah I tried they really push it
actually they really encourage it they
really push you they put like a tutorial
when you load up Photoshop for the first
time after the install it's and that is
that is incredibly if you again I I feel
some sympathy for artists who use it
because you know they've got a deadline
they've got five images to make you know
everyone's trying to pay their bills
they click that button to save some time
and they're not thinking about the big
broad ethical impact of that and then
they send it off and then the person who
receives it isn't thinking about that
either not as problematic ethically
because they're not taking art from
other artists they're taking art from
their own
image um that's not true unfortunately
that would be lovely well in the case of
of the Wizards thing you think it's
still just taking it from other artists
so if you're using generative AI to
generate imagery you are by definition
the only place it could have learned is
from B training on a large Library yeah
and and the argument would be and
there's a lot of evidence backing this
up including the statements of the
people who make these platforms now um
which is that yeah all that is trained
on a bunch of copy written no permission
granted art the the irony I don't know
if you've seen this the the the the the
interview that they've that I think it
was open AI who basically said like we
need you to change copyright law for us
because our systems don't work without
copywritten material which is just an
absolute admission that this is is fully
fully trained on data that they really
shouldn't have access to you know I
haven't heard a satisfactory response to
the rebuttal to a lot of that um that
great I will provide one here on the
show for you and the audience that's
true that that I I understand if you go
to a prompt you know a a mid Journey
type prompt and you just say make
me uh an image of the playwatch listen
hosts sitting around drinking coffee and
what and it and it will invariably you
know rely on scraping images from the
internet both as its foundation and as
the fodder of the technique that it is
using um to apply to that I that that
strikes me as a different situation than
a plugin where you say in this subset of
the image
generate I need I need grass in the
background um and I understand that
technologically it's if if it's not
literally the same that it is at least
very similar but I look at that and I go
what is truly
different
about
um uh other than just the sheer fact of
the labor of an artist who is handed an
image and you know and and they're told
hey can you add grass to the background
and they go online and they look and
they take a they see a reference and
they effectively try to emulate it in
99% of cases there's nothing that would
wind them up in a
copyright uh situation over the latter
and it seems like I I find I find it
interesting from a just a purely
philosophical
standpoint um that so much of what art
and artists do is by studying I mean if
you've ever been to like the Lou there's
always art students there in front of
some noteworthy Masterpiece trying to
exactly recreate it as a as an exercise
that's all I have Techni that's the the
way that I ought has always been to copy
something and redraw it because I find
it super meditative but I guess I'm not
I get that you're not reselling that of
course I get that I get that that and
and developing ones technique through
this is fundamentally different than
passing it off and all that but that's
where I just go I haven't found a
satisfa
like Redline philosophically or or you
know intellectually that defines where
you've tipped from one into the other is
it just one of those classic like the
Supreme Court pornography thing where
you just go I know it when I see it well
you can't Outlaw all referencing because
that is a
huge massively important thing for
artists like would be completely
impractical anyway even yeah and I mean
I um again I've always copied things and
redraw them because it's it's fun so you
find a screenshot from a game and redraw
it that's the only kind of art I've ever
really made um
and uh people do it with comic books all
the time where they'll like take a comic
frame and literally like draw over it in
a pro tools or whatever which is copying
but it's still a means for you to a
again you can get a lot of enjoyment out
of doing that it's almost like a
different version of a coloring book um
B I think it's really good with learning
shapes from someone who's better than
you um yeah but if you if you selling it
is different yeah so that's where I I
asked Mike if you are but I did copy an
artist once and they got very upset with
me uh because I basically Googled the
the the game that I wanted to draw and
it was on the first page and there was
no credit in the images section um and I
redrew it and posted it I did say that
it was copied uh but I didn't credit
them so that person was very upset that
I had basically exactly copied something
that they had drawn which was also
copied from a screenshot from the game
and not credited them even though I
wasn't selling it so like technically
even when I did that as not an AI it was
still the wrong thing to do because I
didn't look for credit whereas AI by
default kind of can't credit anybody
like if you're using generative AI
credit sort of can't exists because it's
pulling from such a wide library and
then trying to melt it as though it
doesn't
exist
I I think to answer the question so I'll
I'll throw some I'll throw some
spaghetti at the wall For You Austin see
any Ms yeah so I think the first thing
is to say the labor aspect I think is
important so the idea that and this is
this is this is the sabur right like you
know this is the idea of or the Lites
like that the idea that
technology that replaces work for people
in a society where people need to work
there is an argument against it based
purely on that Automation in itself is
not necessarily a good thing and can put
people all out of work and we all adapt
none of us shed tears for the horse and
buggy industry though so like on some
level I bet there were a lot of people
working in that industry who would
disagree with you obviously they don't
existent yeah well of course but I mean
I mean the broad populist this comes
large no that's fair that's fair and and
over time people care and I get that so
I'll make the labor argument I'll do my
my my my communist mic thing and I'll
move on because that's not the argument
that's going to win you over but it's
one that's I think there is a relevance
to it well C it's it's more just the
idea that creative destruction is what
the sort of Economics economists would
refer to that as is that the development
of new Industries and new technologies
invariably does bring destructive side
effects and no one should have a lack of
empathy for someone that loses their job
in the process of that the gamble that's
being made and this is where
Ai and a lot of digital era automation
tests what has historically been true
this is the Andrew Yang pitch is that um
the level the level of automation that
we're talking about it's not just that
the automotive industry created such a
new industry that while some jobs were
destroyed it create it unlocked so much
more economic potential that it far and
away I'm going to sit in the economic
conversation for a moment I will move on
from this shortly but I I do want to sit
with this for a moment because the
fundamental difference is Henry Ford
worked out to make cars cheaper
fundamentally that was
valuable the AI model as it currently
exists is profoundly expensive I think
the current number is about 35 cents a
question asked of chat GPT so every time
you type in a question to chat GPT
people who are running that service have
to spend about 35 cents in terms of
electricity AI hasn't gotten it's a it's
a crucial thing that we need to remember
culturally is AI hasn't this AI we're
dealing with now is not actually
fundamentally much better than the Mad
Libs in a computer that existed 30 years
ago the difference is computational
power and and the the cost coming down
but the AI cost is still about 35 cents
a question currently is the guess and
I'm sure there's differences in in
whatever that means that currently all
of the AI that people the consumers are
using is being massively
massively basically given them to for
given to them for free something that's
costing someone a lot of money which
means that we are actually dealing with
one of these kind of situations much
like say Uber for example where you make
an enormous upfront payment as a company
to
effectively uh disrupt or destroy an
existing
industry once that industry is destroyed
you can come in and you can actually
charge what it's worth Uber Uber's
business model was Wipe Out the taxis
and then you can sell an inferior
service you know for a high for for a
higher amount the same seems to be
happening here if you are someone did
that with mixer they offered uh uh
people better deals and then got rid of
all those when they had it's a really
it's a really standard operating again
capitalism sorry kind of situation and
if you're someone and The crucial part
here as well is it it CL it combines
with another currently popular economic
model which is charging rent so the
eventually chat GPT will cost money
you'll have to pay five cents to answer
a question because the cost will come
down blah BL BL blah or presumably there
will be some free version with ads or
something like some some you know maybe
but it's gonna be for a for a while it's
gonna be so expensive that someone's
losing money if they're doing that
ultimately eventually it will be paid as
a rent based process and before you know
it you're going to be paying for a sub
description to a service that used to be
a translator or a assistant or whatever
the job is that's being replaced um that
that job ceases to be a job that is in
the hands of a worker and becomes a
service being provided to you by a
centralized company we've seen the same
thing happen with you know the replacing
of cable by TV streamers by Uber
replacing taxis they're not Uber
ultimately doesn't provide a much better
service than a camp yes there's there's
the element of the app which is conven
venient but but taxis could have
invented that and used that as well
ultimately the reason these companies
exist and do well is that they become
the only game in town they are
effectively operating Monopoly food
delivery services the where the
restaurants that are on those services
are not there because they're getting a
better deal or it's worth their time or
the economics just makes sense it's
because if you're not on those apps if
you're not on door Dash You're not
selling your pizzas right like and
that's that's ultimately the goal of a
lot of this stuff so if we're talking
purely on the economics of it that's
incredibly troubling that we're
essentially going to do that anyway put
that all to one side let's talk
technology for a moment and then I
promise to move on because I'm just I'm
just I am very interested in this whole
area to have conversation again every
like six months which is because it's
moving so fast I just it's true before
that was nfts but the but the the the
the actual the answer to your question
on like a technical level you're
absolutely right the generating a bit of
grass in the background His Image is
exactly the same as asking for a whole
image
ultimately where it comes down to on a
copyright level is you are asking what
is the smallest part of of a creative
job that has inherent value and someone
should be paid for right how much how
how what's sort of like the minimum
threshold to then become below which it
doesn't have value right like if you're
writing a beautiful composition um you
would not argue that a specific note on
your piano you should be paid for if
everyone plays the note C right but how
many in fact there are these things are
defined copyright law well Sharon didn't
that Sharon just get into a massive kind
of legal case around this right there
yeah there have been there have been a
few noteworthy cases uh lately but but
fundamentally there's a certain minimum
threshold of notes I think it's I think
it's five notes or four five or six that
um uh if you if you are if you are in if
you write a melody that has three notes
in a row that are the same as another
you are not suable uh it it on you have
to hit some minimum threshold where it's
like five or six notes in a row now you
can't make the the the argument of
coincident like the like coincidential
or how word would be of it and then
similarly things like you can't
copyright the use of a specific
instrument you can't copyright chord
progressions it's it really is only
can't copyright Rhythm at least in most
cases it is truly only down to melodic
notes uh because they
common language basically the debate
that's going to happen here right we're
going to ultimately have to Define that
for most Industries I guess the other
side of this is and this is where this
is complex morality like this is UN this
is unexplored ground and there's going
to be lots of debate and discussion and
certainly law around this and that's GNA
be fascinating seeing that play out but
I mean ultimately how many times does a
stolen painting have to be resolve
before it's no longer immoral to buy it
like if you by like how like how many
how how distant does one have to be from
the initial crime for you to not be
complicit in that crime and you know we
all live in a society and there are you
know if you own a mobile phone youve
probably wrong someone in the world
right so like there is there is a lot of
complexity to this but that blade of
grass you're putting in that image
ultimately was the what outcome of work
from someone that was stolen from them
without their permission and then sold
on to you whether that's because you're
subscribed to photoshop or because you
you know use an app to generate an
image that there is definitely a point
where that would not be a crime for you
to do that but there's also a point
where it would and I don't know where
that line is until we moving Target I
suspect it will be for I mean because
you know I hear pieces of music
where um it think it's like a VIN
diagram that have a only a SLI of
overlap where I'll hear a piece and for
a moment it's very similar to another
piece but it's it's mostly because it
was
humans at the table in both cases with a
similar emotional goal using a similar
toolkit that kind of thing and they
arrived at a similar uh conclusion as it
were in their process their music
sounded briefly similar and and it's
interesting how there is a scale where
brief little flashes where you go oh wow
for a few for a few me or a few notes
that kind of sounded like
XYZ under most of those circumstances
especially if you think in terms of a
kind of a good faith uh Baseline most
people would go oh that's that's
interesting but at some point you hit a
you hit a threshold where you go well
now I'm pretty sure they're just blade
rising and so it's where how we're gonna
Define that with AI I don't know the
answer I want one more I want I want one
more thing that I just want to say on
this because I think I think it's again
not saying this is right or this is is
wrong but just it's an interesting moral
area the the the the the final part of
this is and I think we all do this we
all do this all the time with technology
and and definitely AI as an emerging
technology and crucially we're calling
it AI it's a it's a it's it's not AI
it's it's it's Mad Libs it's just mad
libs it's just it's true we we humanize
things we aniz things we say this is
when you're when you're when you're
where where did we immediately jump in
the conversation when we were talking
about this Alana thought of the time she
traced something and I'm sorry Alana
tracing something or or being inspired
by something or or flat out awfully copy
something right was directly
copied that is still going through the
mind of you in that process and being
transformed by a human mind and your
creativity and your life experience even
if you're D duplicating it there is
still a human involved there the act of
a computer copying and pasting something
is not creation it it really isn't at
least with these models I Believe real
AI will exist one day and I'm sure it'll
be wonderful and I hope it likes me um
don't want to get into any basist
situation here um but what we have right
now is not that what we have right now
is uh essentially creative laundering
it's not actually doing that even you
Austin when you use that example of
hearing the two bits of music that sound
a bit alike because two composers came
up with them no that's not what we're
talking about here no AI is yeah I'm
under I know that's what you're saying
but like that's different right that if
if you'd heard that piece of music
you're like oh that sounds a bit like
the other thing and then you looked into
it and You' gone oh that guy just stole
the first like that guy stole those
notes and put them in with no intent no
Creative Vision just did it that would
change your opinion of of of that
placement I think that specific context
right now there's a lot of companies
that benefit from us thinking of AI as
we would a human even a stupid human
it's not it's not capable of doing that
it's not thinking in that way it is
simply duplicating and and there'll be
someone in the comments who's like well
you know isn't all art basically just
someone copying everything that's ever
happened to them and putting it through
their filter no no that's not what art
is and and that is not how any artist I
know thinks or works well that is
effectively what my initial question was
though that's the first 20% of your
process but you don't sit down to the
keyboard and go let me think how I can
randomly combine every piece of music
I've ever heard in my life to create
something that sounds like music that's
not but it's not random I think that's
the key is I think okay of all the
pieces I've heard here's a subset that
use this the instruments I'm planning on
using here's a subset of that subset
that have a similar emotional output of
it and like whether it's conscious or
not you immediately apply all kinds of
filters to the
broad you know survey you've done of
other art and and I will say one thing
that you do that the AI that as far as
I'm aware is not doing is you are then
making a conscious decision potentially
the other direction where you're going
okay because I know there's a piece that
did it this way that the reality is if
you sit down if I gave if if me and your
words not also just progam could you not
essentially author an algorithm to add
that layer where you go okay like but
just exclude X you know so historically
it's called fuzzy logic but but it it I
don't think computer science-wise it
works necessarily with these approaches
the the great the good example of this
is if I said to you Austin I'm GNA make
something that is inspired by Star Wars
by what you just said you're gonna do
exactly what I know
you're you're gonna go but your first
step is you're going to go and listen to
every John Williams track you can you
can get remind yourself of it listen to
everything you've not listened to listen
again and you're going to do exactly
what you said and go how do I combine
this what do I steal from this what do I
do where where do I actively avoid this
if you type into a into an AI drawing
software gold robot in a desert
it's going to put C3PO on the screen
that is fundamentally the difference
here is it's not trying it's not using
its wide understanding of sci-fi and
robots it's essentially doing a Google
image search and giving you the thing
and that's an image that it's found a
lot on the internet when it's been
scrubbing and it's going to give you c3p
that's that is fundamentally the
difference how do you feel about it in
terms of Music Austin like what is your
do you have any any stance
on AI composing
because that's happening it's at a
pretty similar rate yeah I as you may
gather from my line of questioning I'm
mostly a big
giant uh sponge of of trying to wrap my
head around it because I don't feel like
I arguably anyone really knows enough
about the trajectory of this to make
kind of
like solid declarations about it I am
fascinated by the ethics of it so I
brought up Andrew Yang for example where
the the his argument would be that the
pace of this level of automation is
going to is going to outstrip anything
that we've ever dealt with this isn't
this isn't like the Industrial
Revolution or Henry Ford this is this is
so exponentially faster than that that
the creative destruction involved um is
going to stratify Society that's his
General argument I don't know I think it
remains to be seen if he's right but it
is an interesting take musically it it
it there is a lot of composers who are
looking at it similarly to what Mike was
just saying about the like stock image
you know for example there's a stock
music whole industry of composers who
write pieces where it's like you know
there's basically there's a bunch of
music libraries that are kind of the
aggregators of these stock pieces and
they're the musical equivalent of
shutter stock and whatnot and their
whole thing is you go in you type I'm
looking for uh I want something in the
90 BPM range it should feel a little r&
Bish but if you have something that has
orchestral FL and you can like type all
these keywords and they've got all these
pieces tagged and then the really good
ones also will which is most of them
like just is a competitive necessity uh
will also provide you all the stems so
you're like oh I you know I I don't want
that one instrument though let's mute
that or whatever and so you can you can
just license uh a piece and so there's
composers where they are rather than you
know relying on bespoke work which is
principally what I do you know someone
hires you for a specific task here's a
game let's come up with something for it
they're basically just writing as much
music as they possibly can and you'll
you'll I'll see them on forums and stuff
say oh this year you know I broke a
personal record I have 500 tracks in
2023 or whatever submitted to libraries
and and and 15 of them got placed within
a month or whatever and they're like
sharing their kind of Library equivalent
of a Spotify wrapped sort of statistical
rundown of their year and it's very
clear I've never worked in that space so
I this is mostly just for me talking to
folks who have that it is a numbers game
and that the way you survive writing
library music is by writing as much of
it as humanly possible because you have
no idea if a piece is actually going to
get licensed and put in something or not
and so they're all bricks
because they no human being could like
an AI uh prompt can write in more in 10
minutes than in a human lifetime given
maximum productivity uh so right now the
more skeptical among them are going
it'll never catch up and I'm like the
problem is first off it already has
because I definitely think it will well
and the whole premise of stock music I
think it's likely to just kill that as a
viable way for composers to earn a
living in the same way that like stock
photography people that would just go
around and shoot random city streets and
and Landscapes and stuff that's probably
dead as well because um the whole point
of that is somebody creating something
that's generic enough that it's not
gonna stick out like a sore thumb in
whatever you're you're using it for like
if most library music they're going we
I'm making a training video for Proctor
and Gamble and I just need a
B in the desert Fierce if you're going
on a stock a stock audio stock music
library for your music you want
something that is the but that's the
thing that I that's the big sci-fi
ethical Mor moral thing which by the way
was explored in subsurface circular if
anyone's interested
uh thank you um I got they're all gonna
be a games six months the uh but the the
that's the big to me the the Sci-Fi rer
me gets fascinated by because that has
been it's what you say it's the numbers
game capitalism has ultimately
fundamentally been limited and and has
served Humanity to some degree because
humans are limited the second you rem
the second there is a competitor to
humans for the majority of jobs and the
majority of jobs in the western world
are ultimately um you know jobs that are
service jobs jobs on a computer so
theoretically those would be be
replaceable the second that happens
capitalism ultimately ceases to serve
the humans in the capitalist system and
we have to as a society decide no it's
true it's true like that's that's I mean
that's lots of sci-fi has has explored
that the like that's ultimately where St
comes from if you if if we decide as a
society to let AI do our art for
us that's that's a terrible outcome from
my perspective
well you but you're saying that as
somebody who values art I think the
capitalism
only is is limited by the whims of what
people are valuing in any given that's
why certain products will maret and not
in
another it's not just demand is it
what's the other side of that equation
well Supply ultimately is chasing AI
destabilizes Supply AI basically creates
infinite Supply theoretically if the if
the cost of production can come down and
once you're in that
situation that's essentially that's
that's the end of cap of most people
being able to work under capitalism I
mean my thing with like I can only speak
to it about writing um is do I think
that AI will be writing scripts sooner
rather than later probably um I'm vly
against it because like what is the
point in being a human if we can't at
least share human experiences and and
express art literally what's the what
are we doing since since the church made
artists in the Renaissance to paint
stuff on walls we haveed on a structure
which we still love we have relied under
essentially money as a concept we have
relied on the fact that there will be a
demand for the supply in terms of
artistic Pursuits in terms of in terms
of bureaucracy in terms of paper
Merchants like in terms of every job
basically that doesn't involve lifting
something um those jobs ultimately
become if those jobs don't have
Financial value anymore then people
can't do them to survive which means
they won't do them and it's and and like
Yeah The Star Trek approach is well the
secondness happens um we do away with
capitalism but obviously that's not
going to be the outcome think that's
possible well I don't I mean I don't I
don't um I I find myself exactly as I
said a minute ago just going honestly I
don't know what where it leads because I
do think I think that's that's the
you're taking the least biased option
that that is we don't know where it
leads and and and what the outcome I
don't believe it or what it's worth
don't think it will I don't think I
don't think AI in its in its current
formation in its current structure could
ever replace a writer I just I
fundamentally there there's the it will
get better up to a point there's a lot
of arguments in the tech world that we
are hitting that point because
ultimately there is a there is a limit
to the llm model as applied to model of
artificial intelligence humans are not
llms therefore you can hit human
intelligence with LM will something 20
years from now 30 years from now hit
that level they well do that's that so
so from my perspective I find it
fascinating from like a Sci-Fi
perspective of what happens once there's
no value in the jobs most people on the
planet do how do we deal with that but I
don't think that's a situation any of us
need to worry about in the next few
years like I think that's I think I'm
I'm I'm I'm fascinated by that as a
question but the I've not seen evidence
that that's actually where we're going
and the only people I see seriously
considering that as an option are the
people who are trying to sell their
shares in their companies that make AI
so I am not over optimistic that's well
I'm not pessimistic that's I'm biased
but I'm biased towards it being stupid
and not really working I think that
um something that strikes me as
possible H for example is if you go back
a hundred years in the development of
sound recording uh and the ability to
synchronize it with film and you had the
first talkies right you had you had the
ability to to record actors and the era
of silent film ended and we ended with
the era of you know we entered the P the
talkie cartoon yeah exactly certain a
certain uh now he's in now nebulously
public domain um but um so at the
time uh the only way to hear you know uh
an orchestra for example or any music
really was to be in the room with them
um and and when we developed the you
know initially the late 19th century the
sort of wax cylinder recorder but
particularly the galvanization
of that occurred when you combined you
know the film
industry with M like movie theaters and
of course radio broadcasting recordings
now the most musicians that we were
hearing were pre-recorded and so it we
entered this era where the you know
fewer live being a live gigging musician
what became a far
more uh you know sort of
struggling class I mean it was always
it's always been that way but but um
recording musician became a smaller but
more fundamentally middle class work
particularly obviously here in enclaves
where the infrastructure existed for not
as a pervasive statement but like in LA
for example and um but uh and obviously
they they were met with enormous
resistance the Musicians Union famously
was protesting that you know uh this
thing that was going to take away all
those silent movie theater pianist jobs
and stuff and there all these like tens
of thousands of musicians lost work as
recording music eliminated the need for
live music but I think that
um um as we enter into a world with
ubiquitous content uh I can see the
pendulum doesn't strike me as
implausible at least I don't know if
this is likely but it strikes me as
plausible that the pendulum could swing
the other way where people go on they
have they have Netflix they have you
know a thousand other streaming services
they have all these gaming consoles and
devices they have their phone which is a
window into everything on the planet and
they go I'd like to just go see this gig
that's happening down the street because
all of that starts to become noise and I
have a newly
appreciated value on the I'm gonna sit
in a room where someone is playing the
guitar kind of thing and it wouldn't
strike me as unrealistic at all if there
if it the fact that there is just
especially if everybody kind of
understands most of what you're hearing
is AI generated I could see that driving
the value of the thing that you know
conclusively isn't which is something
being made across the room from me I I
could see that stimulating what was
otherwise
a
fledgling near-death economic sector you
know so that's where I I go
fundamentally
um uh capitalism is just response to
Market forces and if the market says oh
well this thing is so saturated that now
actually live music is where it's at uh
you've already seen it in The Firm of of
you know bands going Spotify is not
where we make our money now it's already
become live shows that's that's a flip
of the conventional wisdom from 15 years
earlier it's true but but
capitalism love the word going to
capitalism if if if I had it's the
um yeah I I
I I I I think that's a lovely read and I
I think that's a cool a cool concept I I
worry that we have not had a situation
before where capitalism can create
things without people that's that's a
that that is a fundamental size I don't
mean with fewer people I mean with no
people and that's a fundamentally
different that's that's unprecedented
that's
a I I can definitely I definitely
understand
and the the kind of
dystopian hypotheticals of these kinds
of things where they say again I find
them interesting I don't think we're
going there because I don't I I think AI
is kind of so I don't think we're
going there but but I but but I think I
think as a culture we may have to tackle
that question at some point to answer
the question that set me off on this
line of questions
uh would beat Kong I think um I have you
know there are if you talk to Al if you
talk to John Williams he finds I want to
do
yes speed often um now I know you're
lying because uh I suspect he's not even
speed dialable this is his the grid of a
guy as you can imagine I occasionally
stay at a friends place that backs onto
his
property you see is you just sort of
pretend he's there
from yeah it's a beautiful place um he
um he is famously essentially audite
musically where he writes everything by
hand pencil and paper and has zero
interest and never had any interest even
as 30 years ago uh the technology
changed H or new options were made
available and very quickly were wild
widely adopted he's one of the few
holdouts um
and uh so there are people that there
have always been in when like through
the specific LS of my line of work it's
obviously the only thing that I have any
semblance of a claim to knowledge on
here in this discussion the rest is me
just mostly asking questions to push
against you know like poke a thing and
see if it wobbles the uh the music
industry has always had this issue it's
a it's the classical tradition in
particular has always had this issue
with a kind of cultural elitism where
where you have to learn the tools as
they existed in the generation before
you I'm sure these conversations have
existed with like EDM music electronic
in general oh any mov go it goes
back exactly the same thing of are you a
real game developer if you can't code
you a real developer if you can't code
in machine language yeah are you a real
artist you know like anilla you know I
remember there was once a thing that
spat came up where she she was painting
with acrylics and somebody goes only a
real artist would only use oil like I'm
like all this gatekeeping so
everybody's always trying to plant their
flag in whatever little niche they like
and they go anybody outside of this uh
is um you know sort of the tools are
doing the work for them that makes it
somehow no problem with tools I got a
problem with Replacements and I think if
a tool is replacing a job then it's a
tool that's serving someone higher up
the ladder rather than the person whose
job is replacing right no one no one
willingly does l okay but but there are
strings in Thomas Was Alone that are not
played by real people so like there are
sampled instruments that is oh yeah yeah
yeah 100% placed up real person yeah and
that real person probably was annoying
when that happened I'm not I'm not
claiming no but that's the thing there
is no that's not true I mean there there
is no one human that lost that job like
that there's no one to point to to go
who was annoyed at the lack of the work
opportunity there in the same way that
no not in that not in that case but but
I mean even the word ladik right like as
a podcast we all know what the word L
where the origin of ladik comes from
right you know what ladik was uh I knew
this at some point but you're making
realize I don't remember so it was a
protest movement against um like cotton
Mills I think it was let me Google that
I think it was called
Ms yeah point point being the longest
short of it while you look that up a l
is just someone who's scared of losing
their job to to a machine that's what L
was
historically prot anti- technology on
the basis that we the way it is now is
the is somehow I've determined the
optimal way it should operate no the
optimal way for me to feed my family I
think it what again the word Lite has
taken on broader meaning of person who
is afraid of Technology was a very
specific targeted fear of Technology
because they wanted you know to live
yeah position well that's the thing
future we like our cotton Mills right I
like my cheap t-shirt like I'm not I'm
I'm benefiting from those people failing
in their protests right well and this is
where I
think we we we never we too easily
disregard the different sort of actors
in the system you know where I go it's
probably there's there's probably ways
to um automate agriculture that will
bring down the price of your food as a
food buying person is it appealing to
pay less food like set aside additional
wrinkles that we can add about ethical
sourcing and all that sort of stuff but
just on a sheerly technological level
the the purchaser is almost always GNA
prefer the cheaper option and it's only
when you can add those additional
filters so that's where I go as a as a
composer I don't think the audience
gives a how it was made uh like
broadly speaking you know they just they
just want the sausage they don't want to
go in the kitchen they want the they
want the outcome of the process but
that's the thing that's interesting
about modern kind of especially like
tech industry capitalism as we know it
now is you're not getting cheaper food
at the supermarket you're getting more
expensive food after the people who made
the cheaper food have been run out of
the marketplace and that is that is the
that's the kind of capitalism I think a
lot of people in the present moment are
reacting to is not let's find a faster
process so things can be cheaper so we
can all live a little bit better and yes
it might have an impact on some people
over there but don't worry about it we
are now in a point where there's a lot
where the the incentives and the
structures around running a business
entice you to actually not provide the
best service to the marketplace but to
shrink the marketplace so that you're
the only person providing the service
that is has played out in a lot of
Industries over the last decade I think
that's where a lot of these concerns
come from consolidation and
monopolization under a proper Market
condition should be unstable uh and that
we agree and that we absolutely agree
like that that no healthy Market is is
it might have it might have multiple
like big players you know like the way
that you've got that's the dream right
they're meant to compete with each other
and provide the best service and fight
for the the audience that isn't how
Uber operates that isn't how a lot of
companies operate um and that's I think
that's when
people yeah and and that's where I do
think that it's an interesting notion
that if if one company can have you know
such sort of run of it that disruptive
competitive competition becomes
essentially impossible we're already
seeing open AI started as nonprofit
they're no longer nonprofit yeah that
that is an interesting conundrum I don't
know I don't know the answer to that but
I I I will just button it up I run by
saying that um start singing the uh
Soviet National Anthem it could it could
very well be um to your to your question
Alana I've actually said this many times
over the last five years that being a
composer in the year 2100 the St if you
ask a random sampling of a 100
composers what they do daytoday may look
a lot more like a software engineer or a
a a person you know a what do they very
charitably call themselves like prompt
artists or whatever uh like it it may be
that the tools so fundamentally change
what we even think composing to be that
you are the author of an algorithm where
I go because because if you showed if I
showed Beethoven how I write music where
I spend a lot of time adjusting the EQ
on a snare sample this would not
resemble his notion of what music even
is you know what I mean winrey better at
composing than be
over mixing
albums my my concern is that in 2100s
the CEO of a company May sample the
algorithms of 120 dead composers to make
a piece of music and the composer won't
be in the process at all it it is
possible that yeah it could be that like
for
example
um if you go to an artist alley at a
comic
conon you don't run into a lot of
millionaire CEO types selling their
prints and their like it has become very
Niche
because that alone the even before you
entered into AI the stock image world
and that sort of thing made sort of art
so ubiquit you know it was like you go
back 50 years those entrepreneurial
painters and what what not that would do
like the cheesy cabin covered in snow
and sell millions of prints to hotels
and stuff to put on the the people who
saw the writing on the wall ahead of
time made out like a bandit but but it
it did sort of fundamentally like you
know the only way and to the point to
bring it all sort of Home someone like
anilla the only way that someone like
that earns a living in today's world is
through the human to the things that
commoditize the human to human
interaction like patreon and stuff where
you go
it's not about I just have a need for
art I have an investment in a person and
that's what interests me I like to see
the Arc of I really like that point like
I like I like that point a lot the and
the the earlier version of that you said
where it was the in a in a world of
content are you more likely to go out
and see a live band I I I like that as
an optimistic take on this I think
that's a cool and the artisinal bread
versus the supermarket loaf right like I
can see I can see point that the the the
human and the Humane might might might
have a Renaissance of their own and
that's that's I like that I that's a
positive I can order uh anything from a
restaurant on door Dash and have it
delivered in 30 minutes but I still like
going to
restaurants yeah interacting with a
waiter it's a human experience and
especially you know the trend of
restaurants where you can see into the
kitchen and you know and it's there's
big open bar or like a glass wall that
kind of thing like I mean I think that
there's something there's something to
that I mean my God go to Crispy Cream
it's it's everyone watches the them you
know operate these machines turning out
tens of thousands of donuts there's
something about that human connection
that I think we can't that's so
biologically hardwired that I think it
might be though that to your point the
vast majority of what we encounter is
sort of generated in mass and that what
art and those things become is a million
tiny islands of small nich es where
you've got your you've got your little
crew of people that support you and
maybe it's a thousand people and you
hope that the tools could be developed
such that that's enough to sustain you
but that there's going to be you know
very very few but even then I as soon as
I say like as someone who has also
traditionally written more sci-fi than
anything else in my spare time I I
already feel like it has been very easy
to wean humans off of human
contact where instead we are satisfied
by digital contact that isn't even
necessarily Choice with yeah remove the
boil the frog in the water without them
even realizing that they've been
isolated if you look at like the rise of
social media right like there's lots of
data that supports the people are have
far fewer friends than they used to far
fewer have a conversation with somebody
where three people argue about something
for an hour have a conversation with
somebody and they can be on their phone
the whole time really paying attention
to and that's not even really considered
rude anymore like that's just a normal
thing someone to do and I I do I always
try and remind myself there's these
there's a brilliant quote I can't I
don't want to misattribute it but
there's basically throughout history
there have been people saying the exact
same no there's there was there there's
an amazing I'll find it find itend to
you in a bit there no there's definitely
like in like in the in it's like a
Georgian or Victorian era writer talking
about the kids today they don't even
care they're lazy and they they
don't even talk to each other and they
they don't have the values we used to
like this is a generation of Oscar water
um the uh like people we humans have
always been worried about change we've
always been in with something about us
we're hardwired to assume our generation
will be the last so there's a there's
theories in philosophy that that's
actually a trick our brain plays on us
to make us more comfortable with the
fact that we'll die that like if we
actually had a sense of enormity of
human society have related everybody
read the book the denial of death
non-fiction highly
recommended I was literally listening to
a podcast today about the notion of
what's called Terror management Theory
which basically says that
all human behavior is basically what of
death is avoiding death being aware that
you are going to die will shape
everything you do and is like a plague
on mankind it's really really
interesting and that's why I think if
you talk about like
even you know people being chromogen
about the latest tech and and you know
classical compos being mad about EDM
whatever really all that is is just
somebody trying to feel
special the whole time any kind of alism
like that is just somebody trying to
feel special because they have all of
their other needs met so they're like I
need to plant my identity in the ground
and I need to let my identity die
because I'm going to die I that's true
of artists it's probably not true of
receptionists in terms of the people
whose jobs are like there's there's
people who are worried about this stuff
like I think it would be true of
anything that somebody is passionate
about so if you're a passionate
receptionist I would think that you
would be me I mean the majority I mean
the majority of people in the world who
are not passionate about their jobs the
majority of people in the world go to
work every day to pay their bills and
then they find passions they find things
to care about but like most people work
to put food on the table right we're all
of us are very lucky in the fact that we
we do things we love obviously all all
said privilege checked all of that but
that's that's the that's the that's the
thing that's the that's the amazing
marketing that led into our modern
understanding what the word Lite means
they were not people who were wanting to
feel special or or thought that they had
deserved a job they were people who
wanted to eat food and it's and that
there is a there is a there is a there
certainly not talking about it from a
perspective of people who are trying to
keep their job so that I'm sure that's
the perspective of a lot
of elitism that I'm I'm speaking about
there yeah and that and that we should
that is yeah that that anyone who
thinks that EDM is less valuable than
classical music soundtracks of the
lowest Form music this is known this is
the this is true that's what Quinton
Tarantino said during his Oscar speech
so did he really what did he say I
missed that he said um he said uh Eno
moricone is one of the greatest living
composers and I don't mean soundtrack
composers that that gutter I mean
composers broadly he something he said
something along those lines like I mean
when you score your all your movies with
your vyl collection I guess that makes
sense vyl is also a great example of
your counter progress kind of that
people will go and find live music the
Resurgence of vinyl is a really good
example of that as well that we we go
for the the warmer sounding you know
music I um yeah I'm sorry I went a
little bit around te today great this is
where I just I find it all FAS but I do
think that you raised a point that very
much sticks with me about the
unprecedented nature of a lot of these
where if you think of it to its extreme
and the whole post
scarcity the Andrew yangs of the world
and the people advocating for things
like Universal B basic income would say
if we get into a world where we can
basically automate essentially all of
our basic needs food and electricity and
whatnot um it frees people up to be
creative with their time because they
they don't have that need to go just put
food on I think gives people a lot of
existential crisises well but but I look
at it and I go well whatever process is
automating the creation of food would
also be automating creative work as well
those are the things that we're
witnessing right now so if you're in a
world where there's no
scarcity on seemingly anything then I
don't know that we even know what we
would then start to Value other than
would not be wouldn't not be incredible
exploring and fighting the B that's the
answer um it's it's like if you know
every piece of music you're likely to
hear was written by a computer you're
likely not care about music world
without scarcity by definition will be a
world without demand and that means
we'll have to come up with a different
way of structuring our societ see how
that I don't see how that follows it
just would mean that supply has
outstripped demand so far that that uh
there's abundance but doesn't mean that
there's demand so Dem you're absolutely
right demand is a a metric would be like
saying there'd be no temperature comp
demand there would be no demands that
would there would be no there would be
there would be no need for capitalism
money would not make sense in a world
where you could get everything to the
extent of what you need money would be
oh yeah no that I we'd have to come up
but that's exciting right we'd have to
come up with other things to pursue with
our lives other ways of measuring our
value other ways and I be cool we won't
live to see it but maybe maybe people
first will one there but I haven't the
faintest idea what people would value in
that like I can't even be the only
assumption I could make is what I was
essentially saying earlier that
something that boils down to human to
human connection because we forg those
connections through our value creation
processes happiest people in the world
the happy happiness seems to be the
result of social structure Community
yeah family friends community that seems
to be the if you look across all salary
brackets all parts of the world you
somebody I think like I wish I could
remember the name of the study because
it so powerful it almost brought me to
tears but uh a bunch of people on their
Death Beds were interviewed about the
meaning of life um I think it might have
been like Boston University or something
I don't remember I'm sorry um and
majority of them said friendship and
kindness almost every single person had
the same answer and it was just be nice
to people that's that's all that really
actually matters at the end like there's
a compelling argument that if we but if
we could remove all the distractions all
the other things that we fill our days
with what could we what could we achieve
in the field of kindness What
would I'm not so certain we have lost
that Alana I I often look at the present
moment as a a um you know when like you
see a giant snake swallow like a huge
animal and there's this bulge moving
down its body as it's digesting I see
that if you look at a kind of timeline
of technology and cultural Trends I kind
of feel like this rapid shock to the
system in the late 90s as as the
internet basically and computers became
common and then rap you know in a in a
in a barely more a not even 15year
period you know we went from you would
get a CD in the mail that gave you an
hour free of internet access on America
online to a cell phone that is more
powerful than you know than the whole of
the world's computers combined at were
in like 19 80 and so I think that we're
still in this we're reeling as a culture
still from this massive change and that
things will
eventually uh taper down and our
relationship to this technology will
kind of stabilize you even see it yeah
when I I was I was one of the early
adopters of Facebook because it started
as a university thing and I was in
college when it came out so I was and it
was started as East Coast Schools I was
at NYU so I'm pretty sure I was within
the first 40 to 50,000 people to sign up
you were win lost t i remember I was I
was an investor I am a billi I sometimes
wonder well wait wait hold just to
finish my sentence all I was gonna say
was that my class my high school class I
was for a period of time I was friends
with every single person I went to high
school with on Facebook because it was
like this crazy new thing when I go and
I look up um people I went to high
school
with invariably eight out of 10 you go
to their profile last post was like 2019
or whatever because it was the new shiny
object and then they went actually I
don't care I'd rather go hang out with
my friends at the pub so I see it as
like there's that moment where
everyone's fixated and then they relax
off of it so I don't I don't I find that
makes it hard to predict where things
are going yeah and I think I industry
pulls that the valley of disillusionment
by the way that's what we're arguably
heading towards with AI yeah I think
person disproportionately large amount
of unkindness and thus it like frames
myew of hum kindness a little bit but I
also um often wonder if the way we view
smoking now will be the way they view
the way we currently use social media in
the future like is regulated because
it's clearly so terrible for so many
people' never had a very high opinion of
people 50 years before like that's
across every metric right chances are
our grandkids will be embarrassed it's
just that it requires regulation is the
thing for for that perspect like it did
have with smoking right like it requires
somebody to regulate and and but there's
a cultural shift like
smoking you're right that they outlawed
marketing uh and at least in the US I
assume elsewhere they outlawed the
marketing of cigarettes to kids but um
and like you couldn't buy uh initially I
think it was you couldn't buy ads on
TV they did a bunch of stuff to to make
smoking less
it's a really good smoking is a really
good example of the power of like this
this is probably another half
hour I was gonna go there as like I
think me and Austin might be on
different sides of that conversation
perhaps but like centralized um process
was definitely a big part cigarette
which is evidenced by the fact that they
absolutely advertise cigarettes to kids
all over the world right now just not in
the countries that we're in you know I
actually had a horrible dinner once
where I was at or no was I was at lunch
with some people and I realized the
person sat next to to me was a graphic
designer who designed cigarette adverts
for those markets and I'm like wow I've
never I literally said to the guy I
don't think I've ever sat next to
someone at lunched I think is more
disgusting than you for doing that job
that's horrible like you you're horrible
human seen
the yeah exactly that plays the lobbyist
that was the guy was out next to
by British about you saying I had a
horrible dinner it was horrible it
really no I ruined it by being an
to this guy basically but I I
felt Justified very difficult to accept
morally I think it but we could we could
look at people who work at Facebook the
same way and theory in however many
years because you know this this I could
talk about this for ages but social
media currently we're in a Time War
right like everyone is fighting for as
much of our time as possible um they are
incentivized to make these apps as
addictive as possible because they're
competing with each other for use of
time uh they are trying to consume 100
100% of our day with a mobile phone that
is like so clearly unethical though I
don't think it's any individual person
that's that's at fault for that it's
more of a system but it's like just evil
and we're doing it to each other and and
we're incentivizing each other to spend
more time on these same apps that give
us little dopamine hits in the form of a
like that half the time is a robot
trying to sell me an only fans anyway
it's uh it it seems you too you too okay
constantly keep blocking fans robots but
it just it seems
something same every
time weird H go weaving was right about
Humanity in The Matrix where we we
expand and we we will Ex we will always
go to excess is in our nature to get as
much of anything as we can at a at a
individual they're really they're Vine
for right now and I don't think that
most humans I don't think that mankind
in
general has
moved with with this at the same rate as
social media it's it's moved much
further than we have and we haven't had
the time to catch up to the
repercussions of how fast it's moving so
it's like just Happ that plays into
Austin was saying was we may be about to
come out of that curve we may be about
to be his friends leaving Facebook and
2019 like that might be we might be
hitting I guess I barely use Twitter
anymore that's happened something I yeah
I don't check you when we're recording
that's the main reason I I jump on
Twitter that this I'm not trying to uh
you know prognosticate uh because I
genuinely feel like I don't know where
it's going there's so many variables
yeah that even if I had a handle on them
all which I don't even have that you
couldn't possibly I think make a a sort
of realistic prediction but it is
fascinating um I don't think anyone
currently can but somebody will
eventually have
to but well I mean I think everyone's
just gonna ride the wave the best they
can you know and I don't know that
someone ever has to work out what's
happen next but we all just ride the
human that's the Mortal coil is it
that's true denial of death baby I just
say this is the most philosophical we
got in the postt Troy shows I just want
to say that out loud this isaz normally
we have him to blame for this my Troy
for
this that's so funny well I'm pretty
sure we mentioned video games here and
there uh have we mentioned video games
yeah we spoke about game development we
touched on the layoffs I was Googling I
got at least two shills
out did I mention Thomas Was Alone yeah
no we we did mention done three shills
done three shills joh M
heex yeah I uh I was I had a tab open
here trying to find out an answer that
you raised about the layoffs that I was
trying to um find we spoke about layoffs
fact checking a law though we were was
in fact I was curious there um because
layoffs have
become discussion we hear about them
constantly but my hypothesis that I was
exploring was was it that they were
always like has it actually been an
uptick in them or is it just that we're
paying attention to it now I can I can
definitely tell you as someone who's
like you know on the pitching and
business side of yeah yeah yeah we're in
a bad moment right now a fair a fair
thing to explore but yeah last year was
like the percentage that it had
increased was by the money's drying up
basically across the scary I mean the
effect of the pandemic and all the
hiring bonanas that had occurred
um also with the perception of lower
costs as a lot of people went remote
only and lost
inflation politics there's all heap of
yeah it's intuitive that it's not just
an headlines and attention thing but
that's where I was trying to work out
actual numbers like is it a 15% increase
or that's interesting I wonder if
anyone's done that try all together
right yeah yeah I was I was hitting a
brick wall uh pretty quickly in terms of
like some like games business
journalists and ask them to write that
article because I read the hell out of
that I would be curious to know uh it's
kind of like Jason roar's Ted talk about
the so-called Indie apocalypse where he
said um he said you know we're looking
at the data wrong there's the same
approximate number of hits every year
there's just more games released so it
creates the impression as the person
who's who I think inspired the term
Indie Apocalypse in the first place I
feel especially correct in saying that
it's usab bollocks every time um I think
that have I said that on the show before
that literally Indie apocalypse I think
was coined to describe volume selling
less well than Thomas Was Alone I
mention that I do recall vaguely I think
that's
true very bad data it was based on but
yeah I think I think that was the first
appearance of it so I've always been
very skeptical we've had like seven
Indie apocalypses at this point it's
it's a yeah it is a it is an interesting
anyway I gotta run me too uh but uh
happy new year thanks for watch
everybody
[Music]
happy sorry comment section I apologize
for being political
bye